hey youtubers is Charlie and agents of
shield finally revealed what the
clairvoyant is gave us a good look at an
upgraded version of Deathlok that looks
a lot more like this and gave us a nice
time with Winter Soldier it was kind of
easy to miss though so I will explain
what the crossover was when I do my top
moments also more on that because Winter
Soldier is premiering in the United
States or in North America that is this
week I'll be doing a video for that
later this week just a review in lieu of
a bonus Marvel movie video normally on
Tuesdays it's Marvel Tuesday and I do
bonus videos but because of The Walking
Dead finale I kind of had to push a lot
of stuff so let's get started with top
five moments careful for potential
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet but here we go number five Winter
Soldier crossover if you blinked you may
have missed it it was the scene with
agent Stilwell where he said looks like
I have a boat to catch it refers to the
scene at the beginning of Winter Soldier
where Chris Evans has to rescue a bunch
of hostages and capture Batroc the
leaper who's actually another notable
comic book character I love that they do
these movie integrations sometimes
they're really hard to spot though I
think they're a lot more effective
whenever the crossover moment is
something critical to the plot of both
whatever's going on to the story of the
show and the plot of the movie and I
didn't really feel that was the case in
agents of shield this week it felt like
the only reason still well was in that
scene was to be Bill Paxton punching bag
and it dropped that Winter Soldier line
and then just go off screen but I do
give them high fives for effort I love
that they do these things moving on to
number four Skye becomes a full-on
SHIELD agent one of the few positive
moments in the episode
I love the bond that Coulson this forum
with her he really is like a surrogate
dad now if it was unclear yes they only
made her an agent so she could access
the index you know that secret list of
superhero candidates but she's good
going forward they're not gonna take
that away after they're all done that
talk she had with Garrett afterwards was
also really awesome about things coming
full circle
it's like Bill Paxton had foreshadowing
tattooed across his forehead he's so
much fun to watch though all of his
compliments about her you know inspiring
Ward wall he was inspiring her were
totally genuine despite his comic-book
character being kind of questionable you
know he's really shady I do think he was
very
he really is happy that she became an
agent bringing out the big guns number
three Deathlok armors up I think the
best things about Mike Peterson's
Deathlok scenes are the interactions he
has with the tech like watching him
react to the parts bond with his
skeleton and his nervous system seeing
what it does to his mind I don't really
care about all the explosions or
watching him run up and down stairs or
jump super high the armature was a
really nice nod to the comic books and a
really cool add-on but it was Skye's
look at him you know beneath the skin
that really stood out to me
he really is full-on cyborg at this
point you know they grafted all those
parts onto his skeleton so they're not
coming off I totally expect them to
redeem him at some point and you know
he'll just be this tortured hero for the
rest of the series you don't however
long it goes on hopefully we'll get a
season two like if you ever watched
angel with David Boreanaz only now an
agents of shield its Gunn who will end
up being tortured by the memory of all
the people he's killed what I'm saying
is is that J August Richards is kind of
playing the angel role on shield
I wonder if Joss Whedon is gonna slip
any lives and going forward everyone
keep their eyes peeled for Angel
references whenever there's Deathlok
scenes and number two may is totally
added as the double agent we as the
audience totally knew what was going on
after Tahiti but it took this long for
Coulson to find out I like that the
explanation was just way more
complicated she's not just spying for
Hydra or something there's this big
running plot going on between Winter
Soldier and agents of shield about
shield being eaten alive from the inside
that cancer the cancer of shield is
basically the clairvoyant in the
organization that they work for some of
that is revealed in the Winter Soldier
so make sure you go see it if you
haven't already
they actually revealed the identity of
the person who's behind the clairvoyant
and that organization which I feel kind
of cheats people that have been watching
the show you can let me know if you
agree though but I feel like if you've
been watching the show and they've been
teasing this character they should
reveal it on the show you shouldn't have
to go see the movie to find out the
whole rest of the season though is about
this internal uprising in shield the
next episode does even called turn turn
turn
as an agents turning on each other just
like Garrett was talking about with Skye
Mae is just a small part of that and
based on that Victoria hand reveal at
the end I think that Mae was talking to
her
all along I just think hand doesn't
trust anyone and is using her to monitor
Coulson you know she doesn't trust
Coulson and Coulson doesn't trust her
turn turn turn and my number one moment
the clairvoyant is revealed as an actual
SHIELD agent not is an actual metahuman
so this was a bit of a confusing moment
but the man in the chair was played by
Brad Dourif the actor playing Thomas
nashe he's not a comic book character
and when he said that Poe was the one
that started calling him the clairvoyant
he was being truthful the twist is is
that he's not the true clairvoyant it's
someone or something inside shield if
you didn't see it I actually did a silly
video you know suggesting Loki was the
clairvoyant you know just for fun but my
real assertion has been that it was
really a form of AI just because it
makes a lot more sense that Marvel would
try to tee up the idea of AI to get
everyone ready mentally for Ultron in
age of Ultron next year I totally don't
want to spoil a Winter Soldier but if
you've seen it then you know what I'm
talking about
Coulson says it himself it's someone who
has access to all of shields databases
and information that's why Nick Fury
gave Coulson the bus and told him to
assemble this team to go off the grid it
was a way to circumvent what that
clairvoyant was doing now it's your turn
doubt let me know what was your favorite
moment you know was it death block was
it sneaky May was it the reveal of the
clairvoyant and just to be clear even
though that teaser at the end was
Victoria hand she's not the clairvoyant
she was just remote piloting the bus
overall I gave the episode a solid
b-plus for picking up the pace big time
I think this shield Civil War that will
play out over the rest of the season
will address all of the complaints
people have had about the show I love
how Skye's character is developed and
supposedly Chloe Bennett even revealed
that that blue alien was a Kree meaning
she has Creed flowing in her veins you
know a la Carol Danvers Miss Marvel she
retracted her statement later but most
of the people who watched her say that
say that she was being legit so let's
just stick with that and say Creed for
now I also always totally love me not
but may actually just got even more
interesting you know post cougar town
sexy time with Ward closin - I love
watching him be pissed off if you
remember that Marvel one-shot he did for
Thor in the convenience store I totally
want
see a Coulson fight scene like that on
agents of shield if he never did see it
it was called a funny thing happened on
the way to Thor's hammer but let me know
what you think what are your final
thoughts on the episode and do you think
the shield has gotten a lot better with
all this intrigue getting action going
on right now so just a reminder like I
said Winter Soldier review coming later
this week I'll probably post that like
late Thursday night so look for that be
sure to subscribe to get it if you're
finding me for the first time right now
you can also click here to get my last
shield video and click here to watch the
Winter Soldier trailer again everybody
get excited it's actually gonna be a lot
of fun Winter Soldier is a totally
awesome movie thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives
you